what do you think about the prospect of
the new Batman Batman film and what do
you think been apps that can be like
this Batman um you know I have no idea
how Ben is going to go back now I have a
feeling that he's going to be somewhere
introspective and troubled and you know
he's a very good actor and I would never
dream of telling him or really any other
actor unless I'm directing on what some
range but how to do it he'll be fine got
a shavers beer now that you said that I
would love to see a Batman film directed
by Adam Lewis
how did you submit to that uh you know
when I first started in TV I directed
and when I was in the Army I started the
Army's first to Singapore TV stations
and it worked as a writer and director
for a couple of years
I wouldn't mind directing goodbye Jerry
but otherwise it's just too damn much so
many of the recent interpretations of
that have been very dark talked about
you could give an athlete's version we
probably get a pretty introspective and
trouble do you want to see a lighter
version of that on the screen happens
maybe but you can direct how much I
would like to see I would like to see a
sardonic kind of rich and maybe they're
doing that as well but I think that I
don't know the way I might do it is to
have more humor about myself
and what's happening because it's
desperate and as I said troubling and if
you can level them add yourself or the
Joker or whatever well I just feel the
audience likes that moment of relief
occasion a new an added dimension to the
characters but you know they'll do it
their way there's a new show premiering
this fall called Gotham I'm sure you've
heard of it it's a prequel to the Batman
series any interest in coming on for a
role maybe as a crime boss or a villain
I'd love to play a bill you know I've
done
villains many times when I first started
under contract at Warner's I played
villains and cowboys and all that stuff
but yeah it's always interesting and fun
to dig in and try to
that is really like
any particular Batman villain that he
likes to sink your teeth into
I gave you the setup well I'd like to
play an even more grotesque version of
Joker or mr. freaks and find Mr Freeze
occasionally in his own environment
enjoying for example a cold son I won't
go on there in the 60 series there are
some sort of public service
announcements you know like for yourself
things like that do any of those pop up
and they go badly yes there are those
moments all the superheroes are becoming
movies
why do you think Chandra is so popular
now on movies and television in the
flash that makes your mention of the
voiceover everything is kind of cyclic
you know it goes around
and indeed it is the day and night of
the superhero it will probably last
quite a while as long as it continues to
Bing to bring big bucks at the box
office assess something and people seem
to like and I think that more than ever
because this world has gone crazy you
know if you look around and hear the
knows great things miss going crazy
so superheroes are a remarkable escape
you can dream with them you can pretend
with them and if it's for example my
Batman
he's a vulnerable guy and he's human so
you can pretend that you you're Batman -
we all have to you know come out of
whatever we're doing
and occasionally dream and have fun with
something because it's a tough world
laughter there's a real resurgence for
your version of Batman home right now
with the blu-ray release with just a lot
of attention on that version of that
name why do you think now is your moment
now
I don't know
I hire around for 40 years
and during those years I've always
promoted push back when I was typing I
decided after four or five years hanging
out on the beach and doing anything but
I better love this character as I did
what I was creating it because people
are happy with it people love so why
shouldn't I
you know I'm the luckiest guy in the
world we've been able to create the
characters become classic at TV and now
the new game Lego Batman 3 beyond Gotham
or Gotham Leon what
golly I enjoy that because am I talking
too much
we're here to listen to you I enjoy that
because it gives me a chance to template
that man in a little different way a way
I think is more conducive to gain
nothing shall be games what I've done
with the character in the game is
updated a little bit but make them even
more Saini and more forceful so that
it's more exciting because people who
play games want to be excited by the
game but I think we've really got a
winner here with this one and only Gore
that man three and by the way it's being
released the same date as the new
blu-ray remastered Batman series
November 11 you guys are going to love
this game I'm going to learn how to play
it I think one of your other all-time
classic characters is of course
on Family Guy what was your initial
thought when you were brought in for
that and did it surprise you how that
that role in that show eventually grew
up well I wasn't terribly surprised
because Seth MacFarlane who's a great
friend of mine and a wonderful that
written him a pilot for me and then I
realized well I'm on set and I have the
same kind of comic sensibilities in an
area
so he called and I said yeah I want to
play the marriage
don't play that idiotic mayor that
quirky mare you could use my name
because I don't want to make in front of
myself you know as long as it's
outrageous and as long as the character
tries to retain with some kind of
dignity which is always fun somebody
falls down and tries to rip our favorite
lines from your character in like the
bottom three like when you get to play
you're here
in the game I wrote down a couple here
if I can take a moment it homework for
us looks like it's time for a seniors
superhero to go out and dispense some
justice or help
I'm Adam West having some kind of peril
let's see what's your favorite Batman
villain first okay the favorite Batman
villain
of course would be careful you know
curious stirring somebody till the D
built about ol life
DC Comics has been up releasing a series
called Batman 66 and it's about your
version of Batman have you seen those
and if you have what's your reaction to
it yes I have seen the new comic
magazines Batman 66 yet it just made me
feel
older you know iris wonderful because
you know I think for an actor who's
really tried to do the best whatever
world
to bring something fresh things like
that are a tribute and if people enjoy
and if it makes them happy and brings
them a few laps whatever makes me feel
laughs turn money it's not what this you
know you're paid for that stuff that's
what I do and have people enjoy it now I
can pay the mortgage it's about the
mayor character on Family Guy and house
you said they can use your name and in
this game you're playing yourself do you
see a sort of an Adam West character
that exists a true is that person very
different from you when you're playing
yourself only in my most drunken life
what what I do is simply exaggerated to
the courtier aspects of my personality
and that seems to work for that
character
it was fun to be the mayor of Quahog and
especially when we celebrate clam day
mr. West this franchise is he but back
in the 60s the franchise was in trouble
and it was really your show and the way
your performance connected with people
that really helped save and revive the
Batman fan base and if not for you and
your show
you might not be here right now I mean
does that feel good to have that legacy
on the background yes it does here you
know that some of my work along the way
has gone noticed rewarded in any actor
II I guess wants to be loved or whatever
once his work to be recognized and so
I'm failing a pretty good event
you really work here but something good
happens occasional did you have have any
trouble losing Batman just by your voice
you acting officially out to him on the
screen what slide just using your voice
to portray the character it wasn't
difficult because when I assume the
character in whatever situation that
older character Batman they're saying it
comes right back it's easy you know you
just slip right back under if the
chemistry's right if you're allowed to
work in an environment that is not
inhibited
my point being that when I walked on the
set during the time we shot back I
always tried to create fun around with
everybody because it was the only way
that I figured that man communicate that
kind of say meanness and fun you know
for the kids and the adults so I was
trying to do that but you guys aren't
having it in front of a little chick and
I feel like it failed
ha ha ha ha ha I'm sure everyone here
grew up with your show yeah nice come
home from school and watch it what
what's it like bringing that Batman to a
whole new generation of young well when
I look at you and I see that that you
turned out ok
oh that's rewarding too because I get
judges I get janitors I get farmers I
get workers doctors coming up to me all
the time and they say kind of what's
your dad gee I watched Batman and that
changed my whole life you know because
of you our mom fighting crime if your
version of Batman was lost in a room
with the other versions of that
and what type of advice would you give
them that's a good question hey I don't
think frankly I would presume to give
any advice because they do their thing
and I didn't and after all their
wonderful talents and they have in the
films you could do they have every
production facility and age you could
ever imagine we didn't but we managed to
put up and enhance whatever we have at
him but they have great talent I
couldn't tell them what to do I don't
know I'd play it but what do you think
would be you know Batman always had this
like utility belts with all the stuff in
it what would be the thing you would
want to have at all time
well I'd like to have a quota for the
mirror maybe a peanut-butter-and-jelly
said yeah and of course bat shark
repellent yeah you know those lines were
wonderful we had really good funny
writers Lorenzo simple jr. the late
Lorenzo had won a number of awards as a
screaming and when he wrote the pilot
script and I read it I said I have to do
it and I've been offered five more films
and orsa leading man thing and it
impressed me so much
as a funny piece and the piece that
might have longevity that I just said of
course with that script I'll do it and
Lorenzo said after he said that is the
best script I've ever written
as one of the sourced actors to portray
Batman what do you think makes the
character so timeless why do you think
it's more very creation all the way up
there why is it endured because you sir
can be back you hang out with me you'll
see all you have to do is be crazy
enough to fight crime 24/7 right and
know Batman is vulnerable music I and he
just developed his crime-fighting
abilities his physique as mental
capacities to an extreme degree because
he was motivated by seeing the death of
his parents you know that backstory
really works for him and what what I
thought really in creating that
character was just kind of a sense
memory that what was it like when I was
a kid and I read a Batman comic book and
then I said to my little brother you be
Robin I'll be Batman let's go out and
play Batman come on up in the backyard
I got a cape I got a towel here I see if
you bring the tool to the Batman thing
as long as it's not gothic dark and
serious but if we have the task of
making it
a bright night then you've got to
remember the fun you had as a kid
playing back because you can use all
that stuff it communicates is contagious
for the audience you've done animated
work done video game work done screen
work and film work is there any place
left for you I want to go home well you
know I had the privilege of doing a
serious thing on this stage the Ahmanson
Music Center
a few other things a couple of good will
be sent a lot of turkeys but you know
you're going to make a living but if
there is anything that I would like to
do I think I've thought about a
reinterpretation about even as Batman's
father I thought what could happen when
things were so desperate that the other
Batman needed help
signed dark army on earth with lightning
and the library building swinging over
Batman's that father comes in and says
son I know you're in trouble I can help
it's interesting see all of the
different levels and character guises or
whatever the Batman can take that's the
wonderful thing about that character did
you get to go back in time and have a
conversation yourself and we're filming
the series what advice would you give
yourself or would you like yourself as a
young man well you know I was so busy
just doing it it you know you work 14 16
hours a day and then there's of course
the press you have to pay attention
there and you try to have a little bit
of the life
every night I fell asleep with the
scripts on my chest and maybe a bottle
of beer and the steak that I had cooked
up or something and knowing that in the
morning that I had to bring something
fresh I mean I personally and I don't
think I'd really changed
you